hello and welcome to this video playing
graph mode and simply not getting again
I'm not getting this reading up gifting
away all those stupid points okay oh my
Evans gambit oh I absolutely had I did
not have this on the board for a very
long time
I think the regular Italian has become
so popular come on Bishop f7 is just a
blunder and I'm a mouse slip King evade
Bishop f7 is ultra ridiculous just to
piece down for nothing I'm sorry King f8
Bishop f7 it's just I mean this is a
joke move you take it and write blog as
a piece up King takes 95 check king of a
tween h5 queenie aid resigns yeah it
just it's ridiculous totally ridiculous
okay at least at least it's not like I
have to resign immediately that is a
good news but no I actually my mouse is
doing new things okay I think now it's
it's back yeah whatever
kingi hate a King f8 I'm sorry again
somebody who's just gifting me a piece
with Bishop f7 great it is great
I came it's it's just it's a total loss
and you have absolutely absolutely no
play and us in this position
and maybe I get to get some shots
because he plays so badly he success I
don't know
makes no sense no sense whatsoever I
mean the position is still so bad that
white is probably winning but now white
is winning of course but he six is just
weird
here Queenie ages unfortunately a
threatened
Jim it's a totally lost it still totally
lost
[Music]
hmm at least I'm not immediately
checkmated which is not not much but a
mate wouldn't be very surprising or it
wouldn't have been very surprising
earlier
can probably just see em take this
these six I can still take the rook
it hits the completely lost I mean it
takes many many weird moves to
okay our position has improved quite
quite significantly
you know I'm winning this it's so kinda
funny
okay I mean yes honestly I still think
it's fair because I mean Bishop takes
the f7 is the most ridiculous stuff ever
and then I play king of a jutsu a mouse
lip yeah this is this is just yeah you
can just take it and you are a piece up
for nothing just nothing go here and
over you can check with white this
I think g4 d6 and and that's it
basically yeah yeah g5 isn't clear so
what was what how was that refuted again
g4 and d5 for something I mean it really
it does not work it does not work at all
yeah King f8 great yeah now white is
just completely winning of course creamy
385 yeah d6 is strange me that just
makes the pawns on it devalues the pawns
quite significantly bishop a3 or yeah
whatever
don't go a6 but it is so lost that it
doesn't really matter all that much you
only screw it up deep in the ending
no doesn't really
that was made in 726
hmm yeah there is not rocket science I
mean head still completely lost only
only here I am only here after he goes
f5 I mean by now I have some some real
play I with route g2 but only only after
that it gets tricky and yeah black is
winning all of a sudden
yeah I don't know what to make of that
this was a very very wonderful game but
I am the kid yeah it's it's a mouse
Libyan whatever ok guys thanks for
watching